alors le jeu collant donc on va faire le
tour de l'actualité média bien sûr et à
chaque fois que vous serez éliminé à
vous devrez mettre le colon vous
retourner faire quoi ma gueule bien tiré
le court derrière un bien c'est en fait
quoi quoi ma gueule
bah quoi ma gueule bah oui quoi gave où
il joue le fasse oui oui ah oui bon
alors là vraiment je le fais vraiment
parce que c'est vouloir
franchement non mais je fais aujourd'hui
je fais pas toujours là en plus
normalement je dois je sais pas ce qui
se passe sur twitter sur l'histoire géo
ben oui ça va être beau jour la la la la
la la la la
alors
bon je m'en suis est pas mieux avec le
collant s'il vous plaît donc on y va ça
pose la question at your hips
c'est pas mal il était très jeune fille
à la perle c'est magnifique on arrive à
aller chercher s'il vous plaît allez on
y va on est parti donc alors je pose des
questions celui qui trouve bien sûr lève
la main et vous avez le droit d'éliminer
une personne autour de la table
attention quelle célébrité a reçu une
visite surprise de patrick fiori ce week
end
harry roselmack mois ci un premier texte
jean luc reichmann où barack obama alors
à votre avis c'est vous qui avez été la
plus rapide c'était jean luc reichmann
jean luc reichmann caroline surprise de
chialer jean luc reichmann et vous avez
remarqué chez vous daguin chérèque auto
quand les gens qui ont une belle voix
comme patrick fiori qui a une très belle
voix quand il chante joyeux animé choix
gaza ni berset ahmed kanté pour toi
c'est que tu es papin nom et louis noël
quand tu descendras du ciel
oui dossier
avec des joujoux par milliers comme ça
les gars sont personnes et chanter des
chansons de foot enrichit la danse des
canards qui font de coincoin au-dessous
de l'ama oui la marque
les gars et c'est magnifique c'est
j'adore ben voilà bon merci enora vous
et demi de clichés que vous l'aimez pour
qu'on le garde pour la fin mais je vais
et demi avec la verdez à la vernède en
liberté mais son extension les enfants
ne ferait pas ça chez vous allez gilles
s'il vous plaît merci un fils at et
j'espère que ça va passer clown et là le
bât france télécom en dalida ça ne
tiendra pas la mauricie si on lui
demande de se retourner c'est pour que
voilà pour causer la surprise merci
attention gilles
[Applaudissements]
mais d'autres secteurs
attendez mais quelques mares regardez
moi comme il habite
mais c'est pousser pour le sauver j'ai
pour le sauver il fait n'importe bien
mais oui il n'a pas bien lisse et c'est
comme ça mal à l'aise pour dire et un
spermatozoïde
voilà
[Musique]